Merhabalar ben ellerinizi açmanızı
isteyeceğim Ellerinize bakmanızı
isteyeceğim özellikle parmak uçlarınıza
bakmak bakmanızı isteyeceğim parmak
izimiz ne kadar eşsiz değil mi Ne kadar
bize anlatıyor ne kadar farklı Hatta
Kimliğimizi ortaya koyacak kadar bize
sağlığımızın ne kadar farklı olduğunu
hatırlatacak kadar
farklı parmak izlerimiz bizim Eee o
kadar farklı ki tek yumurta ikizimiz
bile birbirinden farklıdır aynı
sağlığımız gibi sağlıkta da sağlık
okuryazarlığında da aslında bu
farklılığımız farkına varmamız
sağlayacak Şimdi sizlerle bir oyun
oynayacağız bu oyunumuzda charl horms
olacağız aynı onun gibi pardüsü müzü
giyeceğiz şapkamızı takacağız ve elimize
merceği alacağız merceği aldığımızda da
haberleri büyüteç içerisinde
inceleyeceğiz tein altına aldığımızda
elimizde bir harita olacak bu haritada
belli duraklara uğrayacağız ve bu
duraklardan ipuçları toplayacağız
ipuçlarını toplarken Özellikle bazı
noktalara dikkat edeceğiz Çünkü bazı
duraklarda farklı anahtarlar alacağız
yanımıza nasıl parmak izimizi arayacağız
Çünkü ve daha Sağlıklı yaşayabilmek için
ne yapmamız gerektiğini anlayacağız
şimdi ilk olarak başlıklar durağına
uğrayacağız başlıklar durağında Eee hep
karşımıza çıkan her derde deva ölüm
dışında her şeye iyi gelen haber
başlıklarıyla çok karşılaşırız ve bu
başlıklarla karşılaştığımız zaman da
genellikle böyle etkileniriz Gerçekten
böyle mi diye ama sonrasında bir
bakıyoruz her sene başka bir başlık ve
her sene başka bir ürün bize her derde
deva şeklinde lanse ediliyor bunun
arkasında ticari bir kaygı var mı acaba
diye düşüneceğiz ve buradan alacağımız
ilk anahtar bu olacak E bu tip ürünlerle
karşılaştığımızda sadece o ürünü yesek
sağlıklı olabilir miyiz diye düşüneceğiz
Çünkü tek bir ürünü yersek sağlıklı
olmaktan öte sağlığımızı kaybederiz
Bunun dışında uğrayacağım başka bir
duraks E başka bir
başlıksız Evimizde kullandığımız
yemeğimizi yaparken özellikle tercih
ettiğimiz mutfağımızdaki ürünleri
karıştırıp yüzümüze sürmemiz saçımızda
kullanmamız la ilgili çok farklı e haber
başlıklarıyla karşılaşıyoruz Bununla
ilgili Eee yani Çok acı bir şey oldu
aslında Bir arkadaşımın başına gelen bir
olayı söylemek
istiyorum Mutfaktaki ürünleri karıştırıp
saçına sürmekle ilgili bir gazete yazısı
okumuş sonra bunları karıştırdı yüzüne
sürdü amacı siyah noktalardan
kurtulmaktır yaptığı karışım kimyasal
bir hal alınca yüzünde beyaz kimyasal
yanıklara neden oldu sonrasında cilt
doktoruna gitti ve şu an çok ağır
tedaviler görüyor Çünkü o cilt lekeleri
geçmiyor o yüzden Eee cilt yanmasına
neden olabilecek Bu tip genel geçer
tavsiyelere dikkat etmek gerekiyor ve
onları uygulamamak gerekiyor Çünkü bizim
parmak izimiz gibi bizim yapımız
farklıdır ve mutfağımızda kullandığımız
ürünleri Mümkünse yemek yapmak için
kullanalım Ancak bunu yaparken de bu Det
kamplarıyla işte üzerimdeki bütün
toksinleri atacağım ve bunlardan
kurtulduğum zaman daha kolay kilo
vereceğim şeklindeki algıdan da
kurtulmak gerekiyor çünkü başka bir
arkadaşımın başına gelen bir olayd İsa
Detoks kampına gitti ve orada dedi ki
çok güzel şeyler öğrendim ve bana çok
farklı şeyler uygulandı ve bundan çok
faydalandım devamında bir süre geçti
ardından saçlarında dökülmeler başladı
dökülmeler ilerledikçe bir bir doktora
gitmesi gerektiğinin farkına vardı
doktora gittiğinde tetkikler yapıldı
Demir depolarının boşaldığını öğrendi Bu
da onun çok ağır bir tedavi sürecine
başlaması gerektiğinin ilk adımı
olduğunu öğrendi Çünkü şu an hem
psikolojik olarak çok yıpranmış durumda
Hem de ağır Demir depolarının
doldurulması ve Bağışıklık sisteminin
güçlendirilmesi için Tedavi görüyor O
yüzden bu tip durumlarla
karşılaştığımızda temkinli olmak
gerekiyor özellikle Detoks denildiğinde
k tarafından nasıl önerildiğini bilmeden
Yapılan bu tip şeylerden uzak durmak
gerekiyor ve bunun bir de modası var bir
arada sirke modası vardı e aç karnına
sirke içen başka bir arkadaşım mide
kanaması geçirdi ve midesiyle ilgili şu
an ilaç kullanmak durumunda kaldı eğer
zayıflamak istiyorsak uzmanlara
başvurmamız gerekiyor Eee doğal bitkisel
adı altında zayıflama ilaçları veriliyor
zayıflama ilaçlarının içerisinde ne
olduğunu bilmiyoruz ve bilmediğimiz için
de bunlara doğal bitkisel kelimelerini
duyduğumuz anda güveniyoruz ve onları
alıp kullanıyoruz ve birçok insan Bundan
dolayı hayatını kaybedebiliyor O yüzden
bazı bu tip ürünler gördüğümüzde mutlaka
bunların arkasında acaba ticari bir
kaygı var mı diye düşünmemiz gerekiyor
çünkü bu tip ürünlerde bizim algılarımız
da oynanıyor algı yanılması ile karşı
karşıya kalabiliyoruz algı yanılması ne
derseniz şöyle kısaca söyleyebileceğim
bir şey David Copperfield
biliyorsunuzdur çok ünlü bir illüzyonist
ve kendisi O kadar başarılı çalışmalar
yaparken şunu söylüyor İnsanları sadece
görmelerini istediğim bir noktaya
odaklanmalarını sağlıyorum ve onların
odaklanmalarını başardığım zaman arkada
farklı bir mekanizma oluyor ve bu
mekanizmayı görmelerini istemiyorum
Sadece benim istediğim yeri görmelerini
sağlıyorum ancak arkadaki mekanizmada
Aslında olayın sihri yatıyor diyor O
yüzden algılarımız la yönetilmek
oynanmak oynanması yerine biz
algılarımızı kontrol ettiğimiz zaman
hayatımızı kontrol altına alırız doğal
bitkisel ya da güvenilir gibi
kelimelerin arkasına saklanan bazı
ürünlerden kendimizi korumamız gerekiyor
buna Mesela Eee mucize kelimesini de
ekleyebiliriz Çünkü elimizde bir sihirli
değnek olsa ya da bir iksir olsa ve o
iksiri versek bütün hastalıkları zdan
kurtulsak ya da daha sağlıklı
yaşayabilsem yok Ve böyle bir mucizede
maalesef mümkün değil o yüzden bu tip
haberler gördüğümüzde algılarımız da
oynanmasına engel olmamız gerekiyor
çünkü algılarımız da oynanırken çok
farklı kelimeler kullanılıyor Bizler
sırlara meraklıyız dır Eee ve o sırları
çözüp şifreleri bulmayı çok isteriz ve
beynin şifresi çözülüyor gibi
başlıklarla verilen haberlerde
genellikle böyle inanırız e gerçekten
çözüldü mü deriz oysa o haberin
kaynağında asıl anlatılan şey şudur
bilim insanları bir araştırma
yapmışlardır araştırmanın sonucunda
beynimizle ilgili belki küçücük bir
parçasıyla ilgili bir veri elde
etmişlerdir ancak gazeteci buna der ki
bunu ben bu şekilde yazarsam çok fazla
okunmaz ama beyne şifreleri çözüldü
dersem kesinlikle okunur Öyle olunca da
biz hemen böyle bir başlık gör ümüz
Gerçekten bu bunun kaynağı nedir diye
mutlaka bakmamız gerekiyor Mesela
gazetecilerin Eee gönülden Nobel ödülü
verdiği bazı bilimsel çalışmalar vardır
Nobel şey Nobel alacak ya da Nobel aday
bilimsel çalışma diyebiliyorlar bazı
haberlerde de Oysa geçtiğimiz sene çok
böyle gurur duyduğumuz bir bilim insanı
vardı Aziz Sancar Gerçekten bu tip
çalışma yapılırsa Nobel alacaktır zaten
o yüzden bu tip dikkat çekici
başlıklardan kendimizi korumamız
gerekiyor Bir de doktorları şaşırtan
bilim insanlarını şaşırtan çalışmalar
diye de haberler yapılıyor bir bilimsel
çalışma ile ilgili haber yapılacaktır ve
işte doktorları şaşırtan çalışma diye
verirler Doktorlar her gün çok farklı
vakalarla karşılaşırlar ve bu vakaları
göre göre göre göre alışırlar eğer
gerçekten ilginç bir vakaya dünyada ilk
tekse bu Tıp literatürüne gir
bilimsel bir dergide yayınlanacaktır ve
tıp kongrelerinde sunulacaktır o yüzden
bu tip bir haberle karşılaşırsanız
haberin içerisinde mutlaka nerede
yayınlandığını bakın yoksa doktorların
şaşırtacak kadar haberler İnanın her gün
karşılaşılmış Şimdi biz Dedektif olduk
Sherlock Holmes gibi elimizde bir harita
var ilk durağımız başlıklı şimdi ik
duraktaki uğrayacağız Duygu yönetimi
gerçekten çok önemli çünkü bize haberler
genellikle hikaye şeklinde anlatılır bir
hikaye olduğunda da biz duygularımızın
seline kapılırız Bununla ilgili Sherlock
holmes'e Dr Watson bir gün soru soruyor
diyor ki sen olayları nasıl çözebiliyor
musun bu şekilde diyor yani nasıl
etkilenmiyon işleyebileceği
düşünemedim ve o kadının 8iz tane
cinayetten sorumlu olduğunu ve bir katil
olduğunu seri katil olduğunu
öğrendiğimde hata yaptığımı Anladım
sonra başka bir vakayla karşılaştım çok
çirkin itici kesinlikle bu katildir
dediğim bir adamın Aslında masum
olduğunu öğrendim ve şehirdeki fakirlere
ne kadar destek olup yardım ettiğini
öğrendiğimde duygularımın beni yanlış
yönlendirdiğini anladım diyor ve o O
günden sonra baktığım her olayda
duygularımdan kurtularak duygularımdan
arınarak olayları ele almam gerektiğini
Anladım diyor Sizler haberlerde bir
çocuğun hikayesi bir kadının hikayesi ya
da bir yaşlının hikayesi özellikle acı
duyularak böyle ajitasyon yapılarak
verildiğinde hemen aklınıza Ben bir
frene basayım bu olayın arkasında Acaba
ne gizli diye düşünmenizi öneririm çünkü
Orada aslında arka planda çok farklı bir
olay oluyor olabilir ancak bize daha
farklı şekilde ele alarak anlatıyor
olabilirler sonra başka bir durağa
uğrayacağız bu Durak Uzmanlar Durağı bu
karikatürü okumanızı rica
edeceğim şimdi uzmanlarla ilgili şöyle
bir kargaşa oluyor diyorlar ki ben
nereden bileceğim hangi uzmanın ne
olduğu ğunu bunu çok basit bir şekilde
şöyle anlatabilirim bir gün televizyona
edebiyat öğretmeni çıkıyor ve fizik
dersi ile ilgili bilgiler veriyor ne
kadar inanırsınız bir edebiyat öğretmeni
Fizikle ilgili bilgi verebilir mi Evet
öğretmen Ama biri edebiyat biri Fizik
öğretmeni sağlık da aynı bu şekildedir
aslında bir Genel Cerrahi Uzmanı çıkıp
Kalp sağlığı ile ilgili bilgi
vermemelidir Çünkü Kalp sağlığı ve
hastalıkları ile ilgili kardiyologlar bu
konuda eğitim al almışlardır O yüzden
televizyona çıkan bir uzman konuşuyorsa
o kişinin mutlaka CV'sini araştırmak
gerekiyor ve o kişi gerçekten o alanda
eğitim alıp almamış mı bakmak gerekiyor
Özellikle de o konuda bilimsel çalışma
yaptıysa çok daha güvenilir olduğunu
olabileceğini gösteriyordu O yüzden bu
konu çok önemli çünkü
Eee maalesef sağlık eşittir reklam
olayına da girmeye başladı Çünkü bazı
uzmanlar Eee ya da uzman olduğu iddia
eden kişiler sağlıkla ilgili televizyona
çıkabilmek gazetede yer alabilmek için
belli ücretler ödüyorlar yani o kişinin
televizyona ücret ödeyerek çıkıp
çıkmadığını bilemezsiniz onun için de
sizin kendi hayatınızın önlemini
alabilmek için daha mantıklı
davranabilmek için mutlaka araştırmanız
gerekiyor o uzman gerçekten uzman mı
değil mi diye bakmanız gerekiyor bir
sonraki durağımız kaynaklar Durağı bir
haberle karşılaştığınız Özellikle de
yabancı kaynaklarda hemen bir
güveniyoruz nedense yabancı İsa Doğrudur
diye geçtiğimiz senelerde bir tane
haberle karşılaştım zay tungu
biliyorsunuzdur diye düşünüyorum Böyle
esprili e haberlerle dalga geçiyorlar
Aslında gündemle genellikle ve esprili
bir kaynak yurt dışından zay Tunga
benzer bir siteden haberi alıyorlar
çevirmen arkadaş bilmediği için o
sitenin ne
olduğunu çeviriyor ve bu Eee gerçek
haber zannedilerek bizim resmi
gazetelerimiz de yani bildiğimiz
gazetelerde yayınlanıyor haber
gazetelerinde ve sosyal medyada gittikçe
paylaşım oranları artıyor arttıkça
dikkatimizi çekti bazı arkadaşlarla
haberin kaynağına baktığımızda Zaytung
benzeri bir siteden olduğunu öğrendik ve
sonrasında gazeteyi uyardık O yüzden
mutlaka haberlerin kaynağına bakmak
gerekiyor Neyin nerede ne zaman
olabileceğini tahmin
bir yazı hazırladım cahil cesareti ile
ilgili bir çalışma yapılmıştı ve onunla
ilgili bir yazı hazırlıyordum bu
çalışmayı yapan psikologların Nobel
ödülü aldığı yazıyor Türkçe kaynaklarda
Nobel'in Kendi resmi sitesine bakıyorum
O tarihte başkaları
almış araştırdım araştırdım sonunda bir
baktım yabancı kaynaklarda Nobel'in
önünde ıg yazıyor ıg Nobel ödülü almış
diye yazıyor AYG Nobel nedir ki diye
baktığımda aynı o da Zaytung gibi
Nobel'in esprili halde sunulan her sene
verilen bir ödül olduğunu öğrendim ancak
Türkçe kaynaklarda başındaki ıyi
attıkları için Nobel olarak veriyorlar
ıg Nobel ödüllerinde bir yumurtanın
üzerinde tavuk şeklinde bir heykelcik
veriliyor ve bu çalışma ıg Nobel ödülü
almış O yüzden kaynakları gerçekten çok
dikkatli şekilde incelemek ve irdelemek
gerek
Bir de çok önemli nokta kaynaklarda
gazetecileri tanımak gerekiyor Hangi
gazeteci Nasıl haber çalışır neleri
dikkat eder haberleri okurken hangi
gazeteci yaptıysa ona göre bakış açı
açınızı da geliştirebilirsiniz çünkü
sağlık haberciliğinde sağlık
haberlerinde bir uzmanlaşma olmadığı
için sizin yapacağınız Bu çalışmalar ve
bu geri bildirimler sayesinde medyada
bir belli bir bilinç de oluşacaktır yani
medyanın daha da gelişmesini sağlayacak
sızdır uğrayacağım diğer bir durak
hastalık yoktur hasta vardır bu
durakta Aslında Tedavinin kişiye özel
olduğunu hatırlamamız gerekiyor Yani
gazetelerde televizyonda bazen açıklama
duyarsınız İşte şu hastalığı olanlar şu
ürünleri yesinler Bu hastalığı olanlar
ilaçlarını bıraksınlar gibi genel geçer
açıklamalar yapılır Oysa Bu açıklamalar
çok tehlikeli ve çok risklidir çünkü
sizin tedavi sürecinizde sizinle aynı
hastalığı yaşayan kişiler aynı ilaçları
almazlar Aynı tedaviyi görmezler çünkü
sizin metabolizmanız farklıdır ve
Doktorunuz Size uygun tedaviyi
veriyordur O yüzden genel geçer
reçetelerden mutlaka Uzak durmamız
gerekiyor şimdi
Eee biz bu yolculuğumuz boyunca
haritamızda birçok duraklara uğradık o
durakları bir hatırlayalım isterseniz
ilk olarak başlıklara baktık başlıkların
devamında Eee uzmanlarımıza baktık
duygularımızdan arınm gerektiğini
anladık gazetecileri tanımamız
gerektiğini anladık haber kaynaklarına
dikkat etmemiz gerektiğinin farkına
vardık devamında genel geçer
reçetelerden uzak durmamız gerektiğini
ve bilimsel kanıtlara bakmamız
gerektiğinin farkına vardık şimdi bizim
hayattaki en değerli varlığımız
sağlığımız ve sağlığımızı kaybettiğimiz
zaman her şeyimizi kaybediyoruz Aslında
o yüzden bu tip yanlış algılarda
kurtulmak için benim bütün çalışma
hayatım boyunca hedeflediğim ve
insanların da bunları öğrenerek hayatına
uygulamasını istediğim şey objektif
güvenilir ve doğru haberlerin Doğru
sağlık haberlerinin olması O yüzden
benim dileğim sağlıklı bir gelecek için
sağlıklı haberlerin yapılması çok
teşekkür
ediyorum